For me, one really neat thing about
the bitonic sorting algorithm is that it
has this nice visual representation,
which connects it to the dynamic
multithreading model.
You've also seen that it has
a fixed regular parallel structure.
So, you could imagine a very
natural implementation using, for
instance, the old programmable
data rays or fpgas.
Now the regular structure also
means that it will map well to
fixed data parallel hardware.
So this includes stuff like sim-D or
vector processing systems as well
as graphics coprocessors or GPUs.
The downside is that
it is not work optimal
even when restricted to the class
of comparison based algorithms.
So in practice, you'll have to make
an engineering tradeoff based on
the platform and
the scale that you're interested in.
The best way to try and understand this
tradeoff is to try implementing these
and competing algorithms on real
systems and see what happens.
So until we meet again friends, Cheers.
Delicious.
[LAUGH]
Mm.
All right, I can totally do this.
I can totally do this.
Shh.
Ssh, don't be so loud.
[SOUND] Ha!
See, I told you.
You.
Am I offscreen?
Am I even onscreen?
I don't know.
It's like butter.
Like butter in a glass.
It's like you I love you